[Music]
on this Friday night the United
Kingdom's search for stability Britain's
conservative party looks to stop the
revolving door as it searches for a new
leader the Tory party has to settle down
and get on with delivering its mandate
plus the outrage over the outgoing PM's
Hefty Parting Gift
ottawa's National handgun sales ban
kicks in but is it really helping order
to testify the January 6 committee
demands Donald Trump's appearance how
the sentencing of a former aide shows
the risk to the former U.S president for
not showing up and supporting grieving
parents Nova scotia's plan to help those
experiencing pregnancy loss
global national with Fara Nasser
good evening thank you for joining us
the race for prime minister in the UK is
on again the musical chairs game at 10
Downing Street means the British people
are poised to have their third prime
minister in two months or the world
could witness political whiplash
Boris Johnson left office just six weeks
ago he was forced out by his own party
after a series of scandals he's said to
be flying back to London after a
post-resignation holiday though he
hasn't declared his intention to become
conservative leader again dozens of MPS
are already throwing their weight behind
him and if he does run he'll likely end
up in a heated battle with his rival and
former Finance Minister Rishi sunak
candidates have until Monday to formally
announce a run and as our Europe bureau
chief Crystal commencing Reports the
first one put her name in the race late
this afternoon
what a difference a week makes well the
prime minister is not under a desk
since Monday Penny Morton who uttered
that famous phrase has gone from Liz
trust Defender to a would-be successor
the government house leader and former
Defense secretary is the first to
declare for the UK's top job calling
herself a fresh start to unite the party
now she needs 100 MPS to endorse her
per PM for PM leadership bid this past
summer fell short missing the final
ballot by eight votes I think the toy
party has to settle down and get on with
delivering its mandate wise words from
Ben Wallace the defense secretary but he
doesn't want a new job he's leaning
towards a familiar name Boris Johnson
this will be uh potentially our third
prime minister since the general
election 2019 that means we have to
think about that legitimacy question
that the public will be asking
themselves and also about who could win
the next election
Johnson may be a vote winner but he is
not a unifying character this is it
folks his departure from number 10 in
July was the result of deep divides with
a record number of MPS resigning one of
those who stepped down was Rishi sunak
another name being floated as a possible
candidate we've got to get away from
this idea that the sort of revolving
door of chaos the labor leader is also
one of the loudest voices demanding
Britain's shortest serving prime
minister forego her annual entitlement
the public duty costs allowance given to
British prime ministers adds up to
roughly 176 thousand dollars Canadian
it's a unique payment and there's
nothing similar in Canada Prime
Ministers as members of parliament can
collect a pension but the Canadian
leaders have to serve at least four
years people across the UK are facing
the cost of living crisis and it was the
number one issue that now people and
prime minister was supposed to address
the new leader will have to deal with it
immediately as the government is set to
unveil its fiscal plan at the end of the
month Crystal gemancing Global News
London
and you can bet Canadian politicians are
taking note of what's unfolding in the
UK on the provincial front we saw some
big promises today from BC's Premier
designate David EBY who has laid out his
plan for his first 100 days in office
today's announcement comes after a
controversial leadership race that saw
his only opponent ultimately
disqualified let's go now to BC
legislative Bureau Chief Keith baldry
for the latest on this Keith EB says he
has plans to improve housing
affordability Public Safety even Health
Care in the next three months
you had some pretty ambitious plans but
again no details today basically some
broad-based themes as you mentioned uh
key issues in British Columbia Chief
among them crime housing and
affordability cost of living and David
Levy again not many details but today
displaying a fair amount of enthusiasm
wanting to get back into the job as soon
as possible here's Mr Edie I am so
excited about the work that I'm able to
do with our amazing team in the
legislature with British Columbians
across the province with First Nations
governments with local governments with
the national government with Business
Leaders non-profits service providers
with labor with employers all of us
together that's the only way we can deal
with these huge challenges we face
I can't wait to get started
so transition begins in Earnest starting
next week Mr Ebu will meet with his
government caucus for the first time
Monday afternoon uh name his new Chief
of Staff begin ministerial briefings he
won't become Premier though in terms of
being sworn in likely until the second
week of November
Keith baldry and Victoria thank you
Keith there may be a new premier in
Alberta but the announcement if a new
cabinet today suggests more of the same
in the legislature Premier Danielle
Smith has some key ministers staying in
place including the Ministers of Health
Justice and education she also appointed
two of her Rivals for the United
conservative leadership Travis Taves and
Brian Jean together the new cabinet is
made up of 26 men and four women they'll
be sworn in on Monday
Alberta's government is ramping up the
political battle with Ottawa mounties
there are being told not to take part
and the federal government's Firearms
Buy-Back program this is the prime
minister declared Canadians will be
safer due to the National freeze on the
sale purchase and transfer of handguns
that went into effect today Abigail
Beeman takes a look at the policy versus
the politics
prominent liberal ministers in Canada's
three biggest cities Friday cities where
the government has voter support and
which grapple with gun violence it's
very tiring
and going to funeral after funeral after
funerals liberals reannouncing their
handgun freeze now officially in effect
it is no longer legal to buy sell or
transfer a handgun this is
why are we taking this decision because
we've seen gun crime go up it's going to
have no impact on gun violence in the
short term over the long term it may
have some impact on limiting the number
of guns available to uh to be stolen or
misused while there is of course
disagreement many experts say not enough
Focus or dollars are spent on reducing
risk factors instead it's not very
attractive as politics to talk about
however many million dollars you're
going to devote to the cbsa this is kind
of boring so you make a big sexy
announcement like oh we are putting a
freeze on the sale of handguns in Canada
and suddenly it seems like you did
something even if you really did I think
you have to look no further than the
last election to see that the Liberals
clearly use Firearms as political wedged
and you may have noticed just Trudeau is
now up against a new opposition leader
they are trying to box in any
possibility that Holly have gains
Traction in more urban writings because
that's going to be what makes the
difference possibly between whether it's
a liberal win in the next election or a
conservative win but the Prime Minister
accuses some provinces of playing
politics instead like those pushing back
on the Liberals years old promise for a
gun buyback program unfortunately
we see conservative premiers
trying to play the worst kinds of
politics the handgun freeze comes
alongside the broader bill c21 on gun
control that's still being studied by
Parliament Abigail Beeman Global News
Ottawa
the commission reviewing the federal
government's decision to invoke the
emergency's ACT last winter has finished
its first full week of hearings with a
heavy focus on the police response to
the occupation of downtown Ottawa by
protesters our David Aiken joins us now
with more on what David Ontario Police
are categorizing is failures from
officers in Ottawa well far if this
week's hearings have made anything clear
it is at the Ottawa Police response to
the Convoy was dysfunctional to the
point of incompetence in his 36-year
career with the Ontario Provincial
Police Carson party always thought the
Ottawa Police was Top Shelf when it came
to dealing with protests and major
events first class but that opinion
changed when party was dispatched in
February to Ottawa to help solve the
Convoy problem I asked the question
what's going on what happened to you
guys and certainly the pandemic has
added an impact retirements people moved
on the big problem ottawa's police Chief
at the time Peter slowly very uh
antagonistic it was disrespectful
in terms of where they're there to help
and he's just not trusted it was very
clear he had confidence issues uh in
what we were there to do but if the
dysfunction of ottawa's Municipal force
was one of the reasons the federal
government invoked the emergencies act a
lawyer for the government of
Saskatchewan which opposed the use of
the ACT tried to establish that the
provincial Force had full Authority on
their own to arrest people inside City
Limits and remove the blockade so it
follows that OPP officers have not
required the provincial or federal
emergency act to be invoked to have
those Powers then is that correct
correct their their powers under the
criminal code the highway traffic act
and to put a bow on a week when the
Ottawa Police Service has been under
intense scrutiny the independent Ottawa
Police Services Board made a
controversial decision to name the next
police chief today controversial because
a new mayor in Council will be elected
Monday in any event that new Chief comes
from the Arts CMP his name is Eric
Stubbs and it sounds like he'll have
plenty of work to do pharah
certainly David again in Ottawa thank
you David
the January 6 committee subpoenas Donald
Trump coming up what the sentencing of a
former advisor could mean for Trump's
future plus searching for names a look
inside the meticulous work being done to
identify unmarked Graves
Saturday on the new reality gone but not
forgotten who is she where did she go
inside the painstaking detective work to
identify the Lost indigenous children
it's fundamental human right the new
reality Saturday at 7 on global
to developing news out of the U.S now
where former president Donald Trump has
been subpoenaed by the house select
committee investigating the riot at the
U.S Capitol on January 6. our Jackson
prosco joins me now from Washington with
the very latest Jackson this seems like
a major turning point what exactly
though does it mean for Trump
pharah the committee wants Trump to sit
for one or more days of testimony in the
next few weeks what's critical here is
the language in the formal subpoena
delivered to Trump the committee makes
it clear they believe Trump was at the
center of the events of January 6th and
potentially efforts to interfere with
the investigation after they write we
have assembled overwhelming evidence
including from dozens of your former
appointees and staff that you personally
orchestrated and oversaw a multi-part
effort to overturn the 2020 presidential
election and to obstruct the peaceful
transition of power among the records
the committee wants are any messages
Trump sent through the encrypted signal
messaging app and any calls or text
messages from January 6th along with any
Communications related to possible
Witnesses now you may be wondering if
these subpoenas have any sort of teeth
and the answer was made abundantly clear
today when former Trump adviser Steve
Bannon was sentenced to four months in
prison and a fine for contempt of
congress all all for his refusal to
cooperate with a similar subpoena from
the committee now Bannon remains free
pending the results of an appeal and he
was defiant outside the court November
8th there's going to have judgment on
the illegitimate Biden regime and quite
frankly and quite frankly that Nancy
Pelosi and the entire committee now
going back to Trump there's a very real
possibility that we end up in a long
legal fight over whether or not the
former president can be compelled to
testify and cooperate and it's not
inconceivable that such a fight extends
well into the new year and past the
point at which the January 6th committee
has been formally disbanded following
November's midterm elections pharah
Jackson prosco in Washington thanks
Jackson
Georgia Maloney has been appointed
Italy's first female prime minister
Maloney who heads the far-right brothers
of Italy party will lead a coalition off
conservative parties which together won
a landslide in September's snap election
she and her government will be sworn in
on Saturday as Italy's first far-right
government since the second world war
but that Coalition is already facing
challenges with Maloney criticizing one
of her Partners former PM Silvio
Berlusconi after recordings were made
public of him gushing about his close
relationship with Vladimir Putin and
appearing to blame Ukraine for Russia's
invasion
a huge Dam in Ukraine's South has become
the latest focus in the conflict there
Ukrainian President velodimir zielinski
says Russian forces have planted
explosives inside the huge Nova kakova
Dam and they're planning to blow it up
breaching the dam would send a huge wall
of water flooding land Downstream
including much of the city of Carson
which Ukrainian forces hope to recapture
in a major Advance zielinski says
blowing up the dam would be akin to the
use of weapons of mass destruction
and with Russian attacks on Ukraine's
power infrastructure continuing
hospitals and other institutions are
putting plans in place to keep running
without electricity and this Hospital in
Kiev has backup generators Fuel and
battery packs stockpiled along with lots
of flashlights and candles despite the
enormous impact on civilians Russia's
defense Ministry says the goal of its
strikes against Ukraine's energy
infrastructure is to degrade the
country's military
[Music]
recognizing pregnancy loss ahead how one
province is expanding bereavement leave
there's a victory in recognizing a
trauma that's traditionally being
ignored in Canada and it comes from Nova
Scotia where the government there is
putting partisanship aside to make
changes to the province's labor laws to
better support women and their Partners
following miscarriages or babies born
still Ross Lord spoke with the bereaved
parents whose terrible loss inspired
this legislation
as an ordeal that's traditionally
discussed only in private pregnancy loss
has never been included in Nova Scotia
workplace bereavement leave that's about
to change I'm thankful we've been able
to look Beyond partisanship towards the
greater good and to find ways to better
support parents a victory for Laura Lee
Nichols private members bill that was
motivated by her own daughter Elizabeth
who endured pregnancy loss at 32 weeks a
baby born still she and her husband
named Ruby don't know if I emotionally
could have pretended that she did not
exist because she very much existed and
I loved her I love her and she'll always
be my daughter an Amanda's labor law
will allow people who experience a
sudden endure pregnancy at least five
consecutive days of unpaid leave
although that could be changed to paid
time off it's changing what it means to
be a bereaved parent employees would
also have protection against losing
their jobs several other provinces and
the federal government already offers
some leave Provisions as they work to
ease the pain of others Elizabeth and
Stephen Cushing's lives have swung from
sorrow to Celebration their 14 month old
twin daughters Marigold and Edith I
think
especially after everything that we've
gone through it's kind of
makes you appreciate more little moments
I suppose with the girls on the
stairwell here we have pictures of Ruby
we have pictures of Ruby upstairs I
think that helps us
to kind of to see her because she was
beautiful and she looks just like the
the twins which is pretty amazing this
time of year is always somewhat
challenging because Ruby was born on
November 7th so her second birthday is
coming up with an estimated 3 000 still
bursts every year in Canada advocating
for other parents is making a difference
I suppose it shows the power of telling
your story you never really know what
will come out of it but
this has been a wonderful outcome that
really we didn't foresee but we're very
thankful for it
changes were coming to effect in January
a critical step toward bereavement in
order to heal
Ross Lord Global News Dartmouth Nova
Scotia
the deaths of hundreds of children in
two countries are being blamed on
tainted cough syrup at least 66 kids in
the West African nation of The Gambia
and 99 children in Indonesia have died
of acute kidney failure the deaths have
all been linked to cough syrups
manufactured in India by made in
Pharmaceuticals and exported across the
developing World under a number of
different brand names tests of the
products have found unacceptable amounts
of two dangerous chemicals while
production has now been halted recalling
the medicines is a big challenge
[Music]
children who never return home next the
work to determine their names
there is a quiet but incredibly
important effort underway in this
country to uncover the identities of
indigenous children who may be buried in
unmarked Graves at or near former
residential schools this week on the new
reality Krista Hesse takes us inside one
Community search for the names of
students believed to have died at a
residential school in southern Manitoba
I'm here at the United Church's archives
in Winnipeg these boxes hold precious
details clues that are vital to so many
First Nation communities the identities
of who is likely buried in the unmarked
Graves being discovered at former
residential school sites
Catherine Nichols has spent countless
months sifting through records looking
for any mention of a child being injured
ill or dead
she's a bio archaeologist working
alongside Sioux Valley Dakota Nation to
uncover the names of children who died
at Brandon residential school
communities need to know where their
children are it's a fundamental human
right
the work is onerous not only because
records are incomplete if they exist at
all but also because students were often
referred to by numbers rather than their
names others were given western names in
an effort to erase children's indigenous
identities when we do come across
instances of children's names
essentially what we want to do is make a
a case file for that child and try and
find out as much information as we can
she's been able to confirm the
identities of 99 students who never
returned home but the work is far from
Over the documents get researchers close
but finding out who's buried in each
grave is even more complicated
for that researchers will need to exhume
and test the remains for DNA
back to you
Krista will have a behind-the-scenes
look at this detective work tomorrow on
the new reality that's at 7 pm right
here on global and that is global
national for this Friday night I'm
foreign Aster on behalf of our whole
crew I want to thank you so much for
spending part of your evening with us
tonight's your Canada is carbon Park in
Calgary we love senior Canada so please
keep emailing us those photos to viewers
at globalnational.com until tomorrow
take care of yourselves and each other
good night
[Music]
thank you